will you know if you are saved before
jesus comes back how will we know
you you you're supposed to know that
you've given your life to christ
now that you know that's the safety thing you
can say i have and this has to be done dearly
you surrender the life to christ daily you
you know i have given my life to christ you
know i'm trying by the indwelling power of his
spirit to obey him you know that and that's the
safest thing you can say you don't run around
saying i'm saved i'm saved you can say i have
given my life to christ and the life in the hand
of christ cannot be lost let me say it again a
life that is given to christ cannot be lost
so you can know i've given my life to christ
and i keep renewing that surrender hello white
rights and desire of adhd 324 paragraph one we
may leave off many habits for a time we may part
company with satan but without a vital connection
with god through surrender ourselves to him moment
by moment we shall be overcome without a vital
connection with god through surrender of ourselves
to him moment by moment we shall be overcome in uh
steps of christ page 48 paragraph one and thus
through constant surrender to god you will be
unable to live in your life the life of faith we
don't understand the concept of constant surrender
because the devil is our heels all the time the
surrender must be constant so you and i can say
i gave my life to christ the moment i opened my
eyes before i left the bed i did not wait to kneel
in that bed i gave my life to christ and i renew
it during the day how long does it take to say
father i resubmit my life to your control three
seconds um hallelujah constant surrender you know
the life on automatic pilot is a conscious
experience it's intentional and deliberate
amen intentionality is what god desires of us
and you know as i was reflecting one day the
lord revealed to me that being a christian is not
about giving up things not doing things anymore
being a christian is about giving our all to
god christ without exception without reservation
when when the bible says thou shalt
love the law thy god with all thy heart
with all thy soul with all thy mind with
all thy strength that's no joke all all all
you can't give one percent of the devil a
99 for god that's like one drop of poison
in a bottle of vitamin and rich water it's
all bad it must be a total surrender to god
total surrender amen well friends we want to
surrender all to our savior and lord everything
we want to laid on the altar of sacrifice the
reason why god lost total surrender from us is
because he made total surrender for us in giving
christ that was total surrender for us there was
no other way we could be saved but by the total
surrender of god in jesus christ that's why the
bible says god was in christ reconciling the world
unto himself god gave himself when he gave jesus
christ mysterious because it was christ who died
but in some way that's very very real the father
gave and i say that because the bible says uh john
15 verse 13 greater love hath no man than this
that a man lay down his life for his friends it
doesn't say a greater love hath no man than this
that a man lay down someone else's life for his
friend the greatest expression of love is the
sacrifice of your own life god said the bible says
for god so loved the world that he gave his only
begotten son wait a minute if you love me so much
why did you give somebody else why did you give
yourself when he gave himself we better fully
understand how he gave himself in giving christ
as i said earlier god was in christ
reconciling the world unto himself he
gave himself through christ and it's a mystery
we will study for eternity when we get to the
other side but total surrender from us must match
total surrender from god for our salvation total
sacrifice when i say match it can't be matched
in quality but it must be matched in totality
in so far as a human being can surrender himself
completely because god gave completely of himself
we have completely from heaven completely
from earth that's how salvation works
amen amen elder skeet you know as you're
talking about giving your all my mind goes
back to the story of the widow with the two
mites although the pharisees and the jews may
have been dropping their talents she gave two
mice but jesus said she gave more because she
gave her all and we know that god wants us
to reciprocate the love that he expresses
white often writes about you know this law
of physics called action reactions so for
every action that is put forth there's an
opposite reaction that takes place with the
same magnitude but the opposite direction so as
god condescended and he sent his son he expects
us to rise to the occasion and express his love
not only to him but to our fellow men that's right
you